era un país que el senado por ahora va a
tener que estar con 50 senadores
recordemos que aquí para son 100
senadores y para tener la mayoría es 51
hasta ahora los republicanos logran
mantenerse en cuenta porque se va a
definir el 5 de enero en en georgia dos
diputados dos senadores entonces en ese
sentido si lo ganaran los demócratas
tendría que decidir siempre en el voto
del senado la vicepresidenta porque es
el presidente de ese cuerpo que ocurre
que sí lo tiene
hasta el hasta ayer a un país están
eligiendo 2-1 era republicano entonces
los republicanos iban a tener mayor y
entonces vamos a tener tendríamos si ese
fuese el caso
un gobierno que no va a poder gobernar
libremente porque va a tener que
negociar con la cámara del senado para
las leyes para el nombramiento de los
secretarios de cada uno de los
ministerios en cada una de esas áreas
entonces es un país donde tendrían que
estar en negociación eso lo manejan muy
bien yo vayan por sus 48 años de
experiencia
en actividad política en esta opción y
eso le va a permitir hacerlo entonces
tenemos un país que tiene que ir
construyendo consensos para poder salir
ahorita de esas dos mitades que está
dividida para allá ahí va mi siguiente
pregunta porque el senado va a estar
bastante fraccionado de acuerdo a los
resultados que estamos viendo y a este
escenario que usted estaba describiendo
de este de esta elección que va a haber
en enero para definir entonces a estos
dos representantes de georgia pero el
presidente electo joe biden va a tener
que gobernar también para esos 70
millones 636 mil estadounidenses que no
votaron por él que le dieron su voto al
presidente
donald trump y que pretendían que él
siguiera cuatro años más gobernando el
país
y usted mismo lo dice hay que empezar a
cerrar brechas hay que empezar a hacer
consensos tienen fácil byd en generar
consenso dentro de los estadounidenses y
creo que tiene bajo su manga que ya es
una persona conocida en la escena
política estadounidense por lo que usted
decía 50 años en diferentes cargos pues
le dan cierta experiencia y margen para
maniobrar y negociar si él él tiene esa
capacidad y lo que pasa que limita la
agenda que llevaban de progresista
porque qué pasó el yo bailé llega a ser
candidato después de un gran acuerdo con
el ala izquierdista del partido
demócrata que representada por bernie
sanders
en ese sentido llegaron a un acuerdo que
se llama aquí el manifiesto demócrata
que donde llegan a acordar las políticas
que se van a ejecutar y había una serie
de iniciativas como le dije el seguro
social de la educación gratuita
de construcción de vivienda un poco
programas sociales en la que ku s senado
llega a tener un senado con mayoría
republicana no va a pasar a mayores
impuestos también se hablaba y está
contemplado allí eso no va a pasar
ok porque es el senado lo va a bloquear
entonces él va a tener que hacer
negociaciones y entonces bueno van a
tener que entenderse y esto que existe
de antagónicos entre el liderazgo del
presidente de trump que existe hoy
producto de ese rechazo también y de su
forma de ser y de la campaña creada por
los demócratas para poder generar ese
anticuerpo trump
bbva va a cómo se llama a ir decayendo
en el tiempo porque el partido
republicano si tú me preguntas hoy las
lecturas que tengo sacan a trump de la
casa blanca pero el partido republicano
ganó ganó en qué sentido mantuvo el
senado y aumentó el número de
representantes en el congreso hoy ellos
están alcanzando 15 representantes más
que lo que tenían en el en el 2018 que
fue la elección de medio término
entonces en ese sentido si tú lo ves
desprendiendo los de la figura del
presidente de trump verdad porque había
una fuerza de querer sacarlo de la casa
blanca el partido republicano hoy se
debe sentir ganador además el dinero que
se inyectó en esta campaña por paz a los
demócratas por ejemplo bloomberg 100
millones de dólares en florida que
perdieron
otros otros en south caros
para el carbón del sur para el senador
que odiaba ni detectaban le metieron al
demócrata 100 millones de dólares el del
el de kentucky 100 millones de dólares
perdieron entonces eso tiene que llevar
a la reflexión al partido demócrata para
ver qué va a hacer para poder unir
porque se ve que en este caso la
chequera no fue suficiente para voltear
los votos en esto